welcome back to Pittsburgh when I says
it was a promo for my fascinating
interview with Dana White one of the
most interesting people in World sport
the founder of UFC has become this
multi-billion Dollar business and he's a
really interesting guy that's tomorrow
night for the hour Dana White honestly
even if you don't know about him you
will want to know about him by the time
you finish watching it's very
interesting stuff I'm joined by my pack
now Associates commentator Grace Blakely
Associated to the Daily Mirror Kevin
McGuire talk to these Esther cracker
well welcome to all of you Antiques
Roadshow shall we have a little clip
from Antiques Roadshow to get this going
so if there's a call for these things to
be repatriated would you be happy to do
that absolutely definitely
so this came about because
um sir Harold kittermaster governor of
the protectorate between 1926 and 1931
this was a back in Ethiopia was given a
golden robe and personal letter by Haley
Selassie uh who then was running the
country and apparently now he should be
giving this back right the family should
be giving this back what do we feel
about this Grace I mean this is all part
of the sort of
I guess paying reparations for sins of
our ancestors giving stuff back that
countries took from each other centuries
ago I don't really see the point of all
this because once you start where do you
start oh well I mean the point is you
know it's you often see in response to
problems like this the idea that I would
have to undo all of human history
because things have changed hands so
many times over the course of you know
Millennia but what we are living with
today is a system of ongoing extraction
and kind of colonial domination that
exists in the world economy which means
that countries like Ethiopia remain very
poor because their resources are
extracted because
um you know they are the people that
live there are unable to move because
they are on the Forefront of issues like
climate change and we as a country are
very rich in part because of the legacy
of colonialism and that's not something
that we've ever read what does that have
to do with this though because this was
a gift from Haile Selassie it was
actually a gift it wasn't it wasn't
stolen well this is I think the question
you know we can talk in the abstract
about whether or not reparations are
good or bad or whether or not shouldn't
we be talking about whether the babies
see in their Flagship Antiques Roadshow
program whether they should be lecturing
people who bring their heirlooms along
they've been handed to them as gifts
just send it back in sort of morally
bullying them or black men I think it's
a historical because it actually you
know people that have these artifacts
from back back that date back to
Millennia actually there's an
educational element there so there was
there was a point in southern us where
they found a giant drum that was um you
know traditional to the akan people in
West Africa and like how the hell did
this get here well because it was it was
sent over as a gift right you have so
many periods in history where you see
artifacts that are a result of trade or
some sort of interaction between
different types of people why why would
we suddenly have this discourse of
giving it back it was it was well
look look according to Ronnie Archer
Morgan and antiques expert in an ethnic
tribal and folk art the robe is valued
in the region of four to five thousand
pounds it's not a huge amount of money
um I just don't like this idea now that
everyone that goes down to Antiques
Roadshow one of the least like
controversial programs imaginable you
literally open up your garage take your
stuff down and find out if you've got
lucky now you've got to feel as with
everything in Modern Life that the work
we go get their hands on is antique work
show they're calling it on social media
now you've got to feel guilty you've got
to be bullied into sending it somewhere
out of the country because your great
great grandfather who was gifted it
didn't realize in a hundred years time
we'd all feel so guilty about everything
do you feel bullied by the end
it's the biggest rail about the Antiques
Roadshow since viewers complain that
they interrupted the program to show the
release of Nelson Mandela after 27 years
in prison
look it's it's a it's a program that
does try to have a more General
understanding and just seeing there's a
there's a table uh that's worth 10 you
know 10 quid and so I think it's a fair
question to ask now and again and the
two granddaughters who have possession
of this rope we saw they didn't object
they said they'd consider it and there
is a whole issue he goes and takes some
artifact to Antics Roadshow then gets
told it's worth a few grand and goes
immediately oh yeah I was given away but
nobody does that it's because if you go
to art galleries and museums there's all
sorts of stuff that's donated to be seen
by wider people it could be the case
here it would be if there was a white
wider outcry amongst the Ethiopians
but the chance the chances are they're
giving this this something that was
given as a gift back to the Ethiopians
and they probably don't have any value
for it is anybody asked Ethiopia if they
even want the damn thing well right now
hey do you want this road
look
it's full of looted treasure in London
the Greeks would legitimately want back
the parthenonsense
stuff in Greece which belongs to us well
I want it all back well there we are
let's try and do a deal why not you can
see the importance of that sleeping
artifacts
because I think this is really important
Ethiopia is currently in the middle of a
devastating humanitarian crisis that's
linked to an ethnic conflict um in the
country that has been raging for a very
long time it's nowhere in the headlines
nobody knows anything about the Tea gray
conflict no one's talking about it at
the same time as the country's been
ravaged by climate breakdown an issue
that Ethiopia has done almost nothing to
create which is largely caused by
countries in the global North and this
issue of reparations is all very well
and good but let's actually start
thinking about how we can undo the
injustices that are causing the
suffering of those people today but I
would rather we focus all our attention
on how to improve a lot of people right
now the why worrying about what was
going on 300 years ago when laws and
morals and ethics were all completely
different now let's try and end on
something a that's hilarious I'm told
because I haven't actually seen this yet
I'm told when it's played to me I'm
going to react in utter horror so we'll
see this is a tick tock video from Sam
Smith
Teletubbies
[Music]
yeah just I don't even know where to
start to see it tomorrow
I don't think there's ever been and I'll
speak of something of an expert in this
genre an attention seeker quite like Sam
Smith and it works it works I don't even
know how we debate what I've just
watched well he's got a career as a
children's entertainer
with the kids face on this thing it's
kind of it's creepy yeah it's kind of
creepy totally agree he's creepy sounds
man thank you no I don't know I mean
he's doing like I would say probably
like 60 of the stuff on Tick Tock is
creepy that's like what gets people to
watch you've got the wrong algorithms
really minor golf shots and Ronald
Reagan speeches
and I used to love the Teletubbies now
he's ruined it forever uh anyway great
to see you Pat thank you very much
indeed whatever you're up to uh keep it
a bit like Sam Smith and
good night